Write a binomial to express
the difference between the
area of a rectangle with length
p and width 2r and the
area of a circle with
diameter 4r.
And they tell us that p
is greater than 4r.
So the first thing that might
be a little confusing, say,
write a binomial.
You're like, what's
a binomial?
All a binomial is is an
expression with two terms. And
really, just to do this,
you pretty much
have to write a binomial.
I'll show you what
that's all about.
So they want us to express the
difference between-- and I'll
color code this.
Between-- in pink-- the area of
a rectangle with length p
and width 2r, and the area of
a circle with diameter 4r.
So let's think about each
of these independently.
So we have the area of a
rectangle first. So the area
of a rectangle, let's say
that is our rectangle.
And it has a length
p and width 2r.
So we know the area of a
rectangle is going to be the
length times the width.
So the area here is going
to be p times 2r.
We could say 2rp.
That is the area of
the rectangle.
Let's think about the area of
the circle with diameter 4r.
So let me draw a circle here.
That's our circle.
The diameter of the
circle is 4r.
And we know that the area
of a circle is 4pi
times the radius squared.
Oh actually, I almost
have made a mistake.
The diameter is 4r,
not the radius.
Let me be very clear.
Diameter 4r.
So diameter is two radiuses.
This whole thing, this whole
distance-- I almost made a
blunder-- this whole
distance is 4r.
The diameter is 4r.
So the radius is going
to be 1/2 that.
The radius is going to be 2r.
And we know that the area
of a circle is pi
times the radius squared.
In this case, the
radius is 2r.
pi times 2r squared, which is
equal to pi times 4r squared.
2 squared times r squared.
Or we could just say that's
4pi r squared.
Now, they want us to write
a binomial to express the
difference between this thing,
the difference between the
area of the rectangle and
the area of the circle.
And this thing right
over here.
So what's the difference?
Well, it's going to be this
thing minus that thing.
So it's going to be 2rp minus--
since I underlined
difference in orange, I'll put
the minus in orange as well--
minus 4pi r squared.
And we're done.
This is a binomial.
We have two terms here.
That's why it's binomial.
If it had three terms,
it'd be trinomial.
If there was kind of an
arbitrary number of terms with
more than one, you'd call
it a polynomial.
If you only have one term here,
you call it a monomial.
So we are done.